the question of like how feminism plays
into the sexual Revolution and the
degree to which are we living in a
patriarchy are we living in a matriarchy
perhaps you know are women miserable if
so like why are they so miserable anakan
had some really interesting insights on
that could we roll that so all of us
here on stage are the winners of the
sexual Revolution and the sexual
Revolution is the winner of the culture
War we finally found a way to have it
all and yet we're still not happy
realistically men really only had a few
Decades of enjoying the fruits of the
pill before Title 9 and me too made male
sexuality presumptively
illegal and yet here we are still having
the same debate from the same
assumptions women are objected
objectified and oppressed though it's no
longer clear by whom the patriarchy is
alive and well though apparently there's
also a crisis of masculinity no offense
but the idea that we live in a society
where men are in charge is funnier than
anything Tim Dylan has ever said both
men and women are invested in
maintaining the fiction that women are
the fairest sex not operating out of
ordinary incentives just like everybody
else um if you disagree you're either
Autistic or an incel or both which means
you're
rightwing and you're not entitled to an
opinion um the problem we now face is
that this unofficial style has been
officially baked into the system the
most problematic Legacy of feminism is
that it made topping From The Bottom the
top down procedural thing so my beef
with the sexual revolution has less to
do with its in incoherent attitudes
towards sex than with the way the
resulting chaos has been leveraged to
capture the institutions the university
the media and so on um what this means
in practice is getting rid of the sexy
60s counterculture stuff while keeping
the sexless School marm HR department
stuff I mean this is the view that I
think most closely aligns with how I
good things uh I really appreciate her
bringing the title n and me too era into
this and basically saying if if we're
living in such a patriarchy why is it
that there is so much um you know so
many so much HR fication of our
institutions that end up uh in many
cases depriving men of due process and
acting uh frequently with this
assumption that they have aired that
they have done something wrong um when
in reality the facts don't necessarily
support that how did you re back to
Anna's
clip I mean she's like I quite
sympathetic to a lot of it um again this
might be like the part of the opposition
that I like agreed with the most um it's
like I said like feminism happened and
like men don't have a place anymore and
this sucks um to be clear I think it's
worth it I grew up I grew up in a
culture where we didn't really have
feminism and if was worse than the way
men have it today quite clearly but that
doesn't mean men don't have it bad today
and I think like we're just like a bunch
of primates kind of reacting to what
came before in n unnuanced and
uncompassionate ways and I think like as
a culture we're sort of doing a thing we
like man women had it shitty for a long
time uh now men should have it shitty
what are men good for anyway which is
another big part I I feel like I don't
hear talked about is like men used to
have the function of dying in wars and
fighting Bears um and there's no more
Wars and no more bears to fight but like
women are still giving birth to children
and having to do child care that's like
an burden that hasn't gone away and so
we're like why why men like I think we
sort of culturally figured that like the
balance of inherent gendered uh
obligations is now um no longer like men
are paying their fair share in some way
which of course is not their fault but I
think this is partly some of the reason
why we're seeing this General backlash
so we just need artificial WBS so then
we can make it
even yeah I mean what I hear In that
clip is that there's a uh that you know
Anna thinks and I think there's a lot to
what she saying that the discourse is
sort of stuck in a past reality that
does not exist anymore and that in some
ways doesn't exist that in some ways it
doesn't exist I there's Pockets like I
grew up in this world like the there's
there's Echoes of like treating women
like that still happen and I think
in most like like Western media liberal
big city culture that like where these
people are coming from they're not very
exposed to like women being treated like
but across the world in
conservative cultures like women don't
have rights um and in like conservative
cultures in the uh America still women
like are treated like secondhand
citizens give give viers I mean Zack and
I know a little bit about this from an
earlier interview uh two years ago that
we did with you um but give viewers a
little bit of a sense of the background
that you come
from yeah just conservative
fundamentalist Evangelical homeschooled
Christianity in Idaho like you know
Pastor type dad um in a state home
housewife mom where I was expected to
grow up and become a
housewife yeah um I remember asking my
parents like why why do you think I
should go to college if I'm supposed to
be a housewife and they answered well
you can go to college to get a little
bit of education so that you can
homeschool your children and of course
meet a husband there um and I'm like oh
that's my
life so do you do you feel like there uh
there's a sort of
romanticization going on in in that
debate because uh I mean I note I I
watched the whole thing in preparation
for this and you know both Louis and
Anna say like they're not for you know
getting rid of abortion or rolling back
access to B birth control there's
basically no policy changes that they're
proposing but it seems to be more about
a Vibe or something like that uh
especially in Anna's case like that we
have this weird battle ongoing Battle of
the Sexes that is mediated by some HR
type bureaucracy um so like I mean do
you share that sense and is there a way
to break out of that sort of rigid
regulation of sexual Norms without
reverting to the like
oppressive uh you know barefoot the
kitchen for every
woman
past uh there's this uh like the concept
of
um wait I'm actually forgetting the term
but it's like when a new religion starts
it's really aggressive and terrible at
surviving like uh early Christianity or
or like what new converts to
Christianity tend to be way more devout
and insane than people who like grew up
in it for many generations like when
Islam first started it was like girl
kill everybody and now like we have a
lot of people who are Muslim have like a
watered down version um I think this is
like a natural process and I think right
now we radically changed our Tech um
suddenly we're having sex without
getting pregnant this is crazy Society
has changed very rapidly and I think
that we're in the process of like very
early stage cultural re rearrangement I
have kind of good faith that like in the
same way that a new social Tech in the
past like took a while to like calm down
and stop destroying everything like we
developed sort of a mtic immunity in the
same way we're going to have this like
we're like trying to figure out how to
handle it like people have freedom and
they're mad at the previous thing and
they're like lashing out and reacting
and men are going ah this hurts me and
like this is just not sustainable like
in order for a civilization to thrive
we're going to have to figure out how to
move forward and my guess is that this
is not going to look like shaming women
who are sociosexual like you can't have
like a wonderful thriving Society
without generating backlash by
alienating a portion of your members
this is just not going to work um so
figuring out some sort of system where
we're like hey wide varieties of what
you want are okay if you wouldn't want
to do The Pride and Prejudice all the
way to Sex in the City like we are going
to be here for you and also maybe have
compassion for men I don't know like I
think just a like learning to have
cultural compassion um because like
right now men are sort of the other
they're uh they're considered like the
villain role um and I think as more
people are like giving birth to men and
raising men and like figuring out how to
make that work I think we're going to
see us chill out culturally
what was the thing said on the debate
stage that you most disagreed with
something the clips that we showed Oh I
mean I mean I don't remember but
probably if they were talking about
violent porn at all that that's usually
the one where I'm like that mostly I can
find like a good argument for the other
side like well yeah I could see it you
know this true for some people but with
the that's always a thing that gets me
is like oh the male sexuality like oh
we're catering to like men want to just
have ridiculous sex with women that they
women don't want like I mean in a way
you're you it seems your project is to
push the sexual Revolution further
because you are an advocate for
decriminalizing legalizing all sex work
that would be a major change in American
culture do you have any expectations as
to if that were ever iiz what would that
look like like what what sort of
changes might we expect and are we as a
as a culture are we are we ready for
that given this ongoing T Battle of the
Sexes or whatever we want to call it I
mean like legal legal and culture are
different questions and they're hard
like if I like were in control would I
change some laws sure if I were control
would I change culture like I don't
think I'm I don't I can't even conceive
of how to do that I think has to be a
slow change and I mean to some degree
I'm trying by doing things like this
like being a public sex worker and to be
like hey guys it's okay there's lots of
ways to be a human and they're not wrong
just because they're different from you
um but yeah decriminalizing sex work
would be a fantastic start um like if
you're going to protect classes at all I
would like people like sex workers to be
protected along with um other minorities
like sex workers can't often have
trouble getting loans for houses
um participating in the financial system
are often debanked um we've had like you
know operation choke point as I'm sure
you're familiar went and did had a
massive chilling effect on uh anybody
doing business with anything that might
be considered OB scene um yeah and this
is all just making it hard to survive
and to do business with sex even if
everybody involved is consenting adults
and I think that's like a massive shame
hey thanks for watching that clip from
our conversation with Aya about porn
laws the sexual Revolution and the
freedom to browse the internet privately
and speak anonymously you can watch
another clip right here or the full
conversation over here